ne plus pouvoir respecter - les valeurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Oui
parce que
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'est pas là
non
d'un côté
je
[Musique]
ça s'appelle
mais non
[Musique]
nous allons
ils ont gagné
la vie
certainement
non
[Musique]
pas ces informations
et ceci
et rien de plus
ou non
non
[Musique]
Oui Non Non
et
deux
Oui
passé
deux
[Musique]
mais les gens
maison
intello
mais
[Musique]
intello
non
[Musique]
deux
bien
[Musique]
le soleil
mais pas moi
parfois
[Musique]
je
non non Non
pour moi
[Musique]
bon
aujourd'hui
avec ce problème
[Musique]
dans une discussion
Et là-bas
non
ré
et
Un peu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
indiquer
[Musique]
et
ré
un temps
[Musique]
de la réunion
ef
à moi
bien
A cause de ça je veux
parce que
[Musique]
intello
plus
[Musique]
non
la
personnes
dans la
rechercher
Mexicains
non
meugler
pour moi
ou non
pour
[Musique]
parce que
Oh
Oui
[Musique]
intello
Oui
non
[Musique]
et
un jour
Avec 3
[Musique]
Oh
état
[Musique]
sur la marque
Oh
meugler
Oui
et
Imaginer
[Musique]
je t'aime
ah plus tard
le thème
[Musique]
bien
Oh
ou non
[Applaudissements]
Oh
à présent
[Applaudissements]
intello
c'est tout
[Musique]
et moi
non
[Applaudissements]
Non non non non non
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
intello
pendant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
et
on y va
[Musique]
aux anciens cibles que le chef appelle
c'est le docteur hannibal
nous allons battre pour être exact
à présent
excuse moi
[Musique]
j'ai patienté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
valeurs
tant
Ce mec ne s'appelle plus
vivre
[Musique]
Maintenant, si j'appelle Cruz, il vient mettre en place
sinistre les cristaux d'aventure aussi
blague à un grave problème de mobilité
du métro, nous sentons les zones supplémentaires de
les personnes dans le besoin connaissent
la vérité est évidente
réhabilité
[Musique]
se greffer et voler la balle, je ne suis pas à toi
la fraternelle spéciale des trois
versions si ce n'était plus mais le
diable et tant d'être ministre pour vous
main au bateau
Elijah confiant que ce drame passionné
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
Wow
[Musique]
je
nous sommes nés pour endurer ce que le corps
tenir nous endurons ce qui est venu et
nous endurons ce qu'ils perdent nous endurons
même si on compte les secondes
notre corps supporte déjà 15 morts
peu importe combien d'autres
semaine
nous fournissons tout
à la salle de bain pour mordre
durer 70 ans
école à l'heure du dîner
Je supporte la ville, du coup ça continue
parcourir la zone pendant trois jours
aller sur la lune
choses combien de contributions
ça me motive
[Musique]
excuse moi
et
lorsque
je
et je dois faire pour les autres
tout ce qui peut manquer
de ce côté
et bon
[Musique]
la pointe
si je peux atteindre
tiens bon et tiens bon
Franc
expert initial cavendish et recherché plus
personne ne jette le mien on endure plus de 20
camps de concentration quand on donne son
mamie acquarone est une action chaude
pour construire un mur nous tenons le
briques qui ont l'odeur de
eau de cigarette en gros
partie de notre vie combien
félicité
comment il meurt ou manque
nous sommes ici
Oh
cela montre l'obscurité
[Musique]
avec quoi que ce soit, je ne sais pas pourquoi
parce que
et
nous allons
non non Non
la vie mais pas
c'est comme le visage parce que nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non non non et par conséquent les ombres
mais non
[Musique]
de nulle part
mais les heures ont passé
la
formation telle
et
c'était la santé de la peau parce que maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cher seigneur tu es assis temporairement
non non Non
[Musique]
avec amour
pour ça
Oui
[Musique]
plus
tu ne m'as pas donné
[Musique]
pas de souci
la vie
[Musique]
Oui
et à l'extérieur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand la moitié
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
content
je
parce que
très bien
ou
non
[Musique]
est bien
bien
non non Non Non
je t'aime aussi
m
bon
en marchant
non
à moi
[Musique]
ré
deux
[Musique]
et
maintenant lentement dans le court c'est
Je bouge mais je ne t'aime pas un autre vrai domaine
hector cuisine la pertinence jusqu'à
faites-nous savoir les investissements qu'ils ont exprimés
plus grillé en sánchez militarisé
carlos et l'intérêt de chucha sous caution
personne avec l'avenant et miki bars avec
ses propres lits, ce n'est pas seulement être
répondants berizzo et dont les visages ici
si je suis en crise de bolivars à traverser
l'enchère s'est approchée où il m'a appelé pour
voter
est la meilleure décision
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est une avance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fait partie de ce qu'ils appellent
vue
[Musique]
le véhicule
[Applaudissements]
Oh
cette nuit
[Applaudissements]
plus lentement
rien de plus
Oui
Je voudrais
[Applaudissements]
ce n'était plus
quand le ballon ne passe pas
je
[Musique]
boggie
quand la gentille fille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eh bien, il présente la seule possibilité de
céder et construire un monde juste que le
aucun ou le simple gratuit
alternative à la catastrophe climatique
[Applaudissements]
pour
ma façon de voir un monde
la seule chance le seul moyen
la justice climatique le seul sac mais
si c'était un système qui littéralement oui
contribue au taxi pour que
sentir la voix du calcium et des douches
[Applaudissements]
un retour dans un autre monde ne sera pas possible
un autre monde est des sécurités nécessaires
60% des personnes qui ne pourront pas
former et perfectionner
[Applaudissements]
et pas plus
nous sommes quelque chose
quand on le soutient
[Musique]
je ne pense plus
quand on parle de
sols
[Applaudissements]
ce qui implique dans un réseau géant de
les gens est
nécessaire
nous avons été appelés à 27 et des programmes qui est de
commencer à se produire si vous n'adorez pas les gentlemen
Monsieur
sentir un dernier tour
tout ceci est un ensemble de photos avec
De nombreux
[Musique]
Oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais non
Oui
[Musique]
et ici
après midi
[Musique]
mais toi
la vérité
les gens
sans escale 2
[Musique]
mais
à présent
[Applaudissements]
nous ne pouvons pas
plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Oui
[Musique]
le sol
ou non
à moi
[Musique]
pour moi
asensio
[Musique]
et déjà
soyons ainsi
actif
dur s'ils sont plus faciles l'a pas donné
bon et vert mais sans le fond non
pourquoi pas dans le coeur et combien
ne pas savoir nous apporte la norme
l'homme fera partie de la galaxie rien
étant créé qu'après son pardon
empêcher la maison trouve ce qu'il faut tenir
et les affaires de la multinationale et de la
drogue
parmi ceux de
Campagne
climatique
fabrication
un grand avec une tendance qui dit de
chaleur et nous nous sommes défendus qu'une connaissance et
commun un seul coût d'amour ou de haschich
à mes dépens la fin et c'est l'alternative
1080 pâtes avec l'économie qui lui est propre
nous espérons que vous vous sentez intégré
les révolutions de la cure parce que c'est
assez calme et généré par le casting
construire mais avec les protestations oui
raisins secs présumés décoller son décolleté
la militarisation du tir
fait partie du jeu a deux des
les filles battent mon coeur et se disputent
C'est un problème sans solution à portée de main
bien sûr tu ne penses pas alors ne pense pas à faire partie de
les solutions
ils ont inventé nous n'avons semé que les problèmes
être franc mais les solutions
avant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Merci
et le chemin
non non Non
et de plus
ces restes métalliques des caisses
[Musique]